three-time pro bowler on the owner of
lights out extreme fighting
um and uh he's partnered with fubu
sports network for the upcoming event
saturday october 30th lights out extreme
fighting partner with the fubu sports
network lights out himself our buddy
shawn merriman back here on the show how
are you sean
rich what's up my man how you doing
what's going on
are you not much living a dream you are
living that you're on you're owning this
thing now huh you're owning your
business you're you're running a
business
i i am i am we've been up and running
for two years and uh we just actually
announced that that partnership on
football sports uh-huh um a few months
back so we just had we had our first
fight live yes and doing the live man
it's a whole different ball game right
like you can you can tape and and have
it out there but doing it live you're
you know you're walking around with your
clamping
you know like oh yeah we're worried
about something going wrong from
satellite so it's a whole different ball
game man but now we're we're live now
with uh football sports okay and now and
and you need people that that multitask
on your team like that's what i'm doing
today like my guy brockman is call
screening and posting videos and he's
over there right chris you're doing all
right over there yeah i'm surviving he's
the one who checked you in twice and
then tj my social media guy he's sitting
there he's posting
he's uh he's also taking slings and
arrows from people calling in saying
that his work is substandard and he
doesn't like it well they know and i'm
trying i'm trying to host a show but i
also own this thing here so my my head's
about to explode you know what i'm
saying yeah but rich rich you know chris
chris gave me a countdown i thought i
was taking off in a rocket ship like
okay call back in uh 19 seconds and i'm
like all right
i just i just i didn't want you to wait
i didn't want you to wait longer than
doing that joe that's right
not spacex that's right
i was about to say this is the spacex
version of a radio television sound
account good note hey sean remember that
time i punched you on april fools on
game day morning on total access do you
remember that one
remember that one i tried i tried not to
but yeah come on now
we go way back sean we go way back you
go you go even further back with my wife
she covered you at maryland
my wife susie covered you at maryland i
remember all of that stuff man so i've
been i've been knowing you for for a
very very long time um so
let's talk some football let's talk some
ball right here
what do you think of uh
uh the chargers you're the current uh
version of the chargers and the head
coach what are you hearing about the
head coach in the current version of the
chargers
sean so when coach brandon stanley when
he came in when he first brought him in
he called me um that night that they
announced he was coming in and we spoke
on the phone about 20-25 minutes and
yeah i knew about him because of sean
mcvay and just their you know teams that
they had up there what not but i didn't
know much about him but when he called
me
he was like he was like over the top
excited man you heard it in his voice
but i also at the time i didn't know how
young he was i had no idea he was like
that young so i'm talking to him on the
phone i said this dude sounds young as
hell that was the first thing that came
to my mind like this guy sounds young
and he is right so you heard like the
the enthusiasm and then two i was
excited because they brought in a
defensive minded guy right because i
always i always think that you know
defensive coaches they approach things a
little bit different practices are a
little bit more aggressive like the
mentality of the team in my opinion and
that's going from body shot and how much
north turner no shot at noah but just
you know it was a different mentality
that was established i feel like that
meantime mentality is coming back with
brandon stanley so i wasn't shocked at
you know them being watched you know
watching the football team they have a
really good team um
i i was you know they probably should
have beat the dallas cowboys i don't
want to blame it on the rest because as
a former player you always told like
let's let's take it out of the refs
hands but it was some calls made in that
game wrestling you got to sit back and
say like and i was at the game i said
damn this is this is a bad way to lose
you can't lose the game like this what'd
you think of the crowd what was what was
the crowd like there because the
conversation
you know for the rams and the home field
advantage that i saw against the bears
you know um there were some bears fans
there but it was mostly rams fans in the
conversation after the last couple years
the charger plane in the home of the la
galaxy was kind of a road game for them
what was what was it like in that
building
and so far were there were there was it
50 50 because it's a ton of cowboys fans
travel what was that
home field advantage like
if it wasn't 50 50 it was 60 40 charges
fans i mean regardless of what people
say but people you got to understand
this too people don't talk about this
enough
california is just a destination of
where people go you know from dallas and
anywhere else i mean kansas city fans
and denver you're gonna have fans there
right because they people migrate nobody
leaves california and move to kansas
city i mean it's just unless there's a
big job opportunity or something that's
gonna change your life or have an
upgrade very few people leaving
california or you know those states and
going to the midwest it just it doesn't
happen as much so you're going to get
the reverse of that so you're going to
have a lot of cowboy fans you're going
to have denver broncos fans you know
you're going to have raiders fans
obviously because that's you know kind
of just their thing um so you're gonna
have other people's fans there in the
stadium but what's gonna change over
time and i've already seen it happening
and this this started rich last right
before they left the last city when they
played the ravens i was at that game
that playoff game and that stadium was
rocking with chargers fans what needs to
happen with them they need to win
right they need to win and start
establishing new fans people will slowly
take off those whatever team color your
jersey is and they'll start converting
to be in charge of fans
sean merriman here on the rich eisen
show who do you have winning the super
bowl this year what was your prediction
coming into the year sean well
i don't know about winner but i still do
think that camp was probably going to go
back um you know i just think that
because they the team that they brought
back automatically that they're going to
have another shot anytime you have that
same core group of guys going back uh
they're going to have a shot plus two
they have they had an off season um
together at this time for the first time
so you think they're gonna have a shot
back
uh when you're talking about on the afc
side to me i think the afc side is
probably more wide open you know you got
um you know obviously kansas city they
got there but you know i i said cancer
before the season but watching them play
the baltimore ravens i'm feeling you
know a little bit less hopeful that they
you know that they're gonna have an
opportunity to go back the afc to me in
my opinion is wide open with you know
three or four different teams isn't it
amazing the when you were drafted in
2005 sean merriman 12th overall
you know and you and philip and elty and
the rest of the crew you know that was
put together was essentially put
together in mind to just knock out tom
brady and the patriots and now here we
are in 2021 and brady's going for his
eighth
it's insane
it's kind of crazy sean guy's 44 going
for his eighth playing at 44 maybe
better than he was at 24. it doesn't
compute at all sean
it doesn't you know what honestly it
doesn't make sense right you're trying
to put it together i know he got the the
tb12 the diet and he takes really good
care of his body and stuff like that but
if you look at you know kind of his body
at work and even some of the years that
they had a down year and he was getting
hit i remember when he uh we tore our
knees up the same yeah i think it was uh
you know eight we both had the surgeries
right he went down to acl i tore my knee
up as well
and i remember coming back to my knee
and how hard that was
uh and just the process of it and you
know you're never the same when you go
into the night so if you have a big knee
i had the achilles you're never the same
once you get surgery to see him come
back and still playing at this level
breaking records when he said that he
could play that he's almost 50 years old
and he said this what three four years
ago
i kind of like yeah right he's bumped
this you know he's drinking that
patriots juice out there right like that
there's no way
but
to see him really doing it he might
actually be able to play for another
three or four years which is which is
insane it is insane and plus he had a
procedure this this past year he said
you know and you know it's
minor surgery is somebody's you know is
minor when it's somebody else's you know
what i mean like that's
it's it truly is incredible uh i don't
know if you saw did you see peyton
manning said uh on his manning cast that
any time he went into gillette that
he would not have a conversation in
front of his locker because he was
afraid that there was a live microphone
in front of it
you're laughing did you were you in in
the rest of the charges the same way
whenever you went into gillette back in
the day you know it's funny because
peyton you know there's some seriousness
behind every joke right i mean we like
okay we joking about it but absolutely
we all did i mean i think that most
teams have played there um i remember
uh how the coaches the assistant coaches
would make us any kind of game
information any adjustment audibles any
pregame stuff we would have somebody
dedicated to go to the hotel rooms to
clean up any kind of paperwork that was
left there you had to you got to find if
you didn't turn in your paperwork
because what we heard and i don't know
if this is true or not but we heard it
by multiple people that they had
housekeepers gathering information left
by giving it to the patriots in hotels
so you're saying
the chargers organization coaches or
whatever
thought
that new england had a connection with
the housekeeping staff in the hotel on
the road and i don't know if if they
still had it at the same spot where it's
providence rhode island right is that
where you guys stayed in providence back
in the day yep right okay that this
hotel where the that this hotel would
have a housekeeping staff instructed
to look for any leftover pieces of paper
that looked like
something football wise and then collect
it hand it over to somebody who would
then hand it in to the patriots that
literally was a thought process of
somebody in the charges organization
that's what you're saying 100
100
and we we started they started issuing
out fines for not turning your your
papers uh or information was that
anywhere on the road or just new england
no it was just new england
oh my gosh
what do you think do you really think
that was happening for real
look i i i don't i don't know who they
you know
if they had a connection at the hotel or
whatever i would be when they smoke this
fire um and i'm not saying that maybe it
wasn't the top or exactly anybody in the
organization maybe it was somebody that
was you know maybe a lower level or you
know the ball boy i have no idea but
right it definitely was a serious
conversation
uh and it was a serious issue that we
had that we had someone collecting
every piece of uh game information and
if you left it in the hotel room you was
fine and when you say where there's
smoke this fire you're not talking about
the other rumor that the patriots would
have somebody on this hotel staff pull
the fire alarm at two in the morning
when there wasn't anything just to wake
you guys up in the middle of the night
before game day right there's that there
was that one
that that was uh that was real smoke
that wasn't uh
that was real smoke with that one that
was true that one oh you think they did
that is that what you're saying yeah
yeah 100
oh my gosh it's crazy football's nuts
man this is just crazy the paranoia that
that goes and and that's good enough i
mean i bet you the patriots love hearing
this i think i bet you they love hearing
it because if if it's in the minds eye
of anybody that comes in i'm sure sean
payton's talking about it this week to
the saints
right now i'm sure
that sort of stuff he has he has to i
mean you think about it um
and like it's just it's just way way way
too many things and i don't know if any
of this stuff throughout no one's like
saying hey this happened or they told me
that we collected this information and
you know don't talk in the showers maybe
the locker rooms i don't know but
you it's been conversations throughout
many many organizations even when we're
playing other teams or you see guys in
the off season and you're kind of just
chilling having a having a drink or
hanging out it's all it's been it's
talked about everywhere it's just not
like you know some secret news last one
for you on the football front and then
we'll talk a little bit about your your
fighting and then we'll we'll let you go
on your friday i think i remember this
story um you know because i when i used
to go to pro bowls i was warned to never
give out your room number because if you
do that then the rest of the uh people
at the pro bowl will put
their orders on your room and then you
check out and your your bill is insane
um is it true your bill was insane after
your first pro bowl because your room
number got around and the rest of the
afc team put it all on you the rookie
did that happen
sean merrimack oh yeah how much was it
what was your what was your tab
uh i i think i had over three thousand
dollars in drinks alone they're like my
ties and food and stuff like that
and and what happened look at rich we
were sitting by the pool i had no idea
i'm thinking you know i want one of uh
two rookies down there i don't we're
sitting around having a good time i'm
you know
looking around and just taking
everything again and the waitress came
up and she tapped me on the shoulder she
said hey you've got to put your room
number one here and i just said you
could put it on there and i said it is
such a and right when i said it
i think it was ray lewis and somebody
who kicked me under the table they
kicked me and said no don't do that but
it was already people had already heard
it so i don't know i think
there were offensive linemen sitting
over there that we got you know big guys
there's no way that somebody could drink
three thousand dollars in my time
there's no way yeah sean payton wants to
to tony romo when tony made his first uh
pro bowl said to him that his son sean
payton's son had drawn some drawings of
of tony romo some drew some pictures of
tony romo some drawings and hey i wanted
to bring it uh he wants to bring it to
your room to give it to you what's your
room number got that room number from
tony romo and then broke the practice
huddle by saying romo's room number on
three and it was on and kraken after
that
that's another story i heard once upon a
time absolutely no joke so ray lewis
kicked you under the table like don't do
it
but
the cap the cat was out of the bag it
was done it was already said it is oh
man right after he kicked me i realized
what i just did but it was it was too
late the damage was done thousands of
dollars later hey at least now you could
get to own lights out extreme fighting
so tell everybody what uh what's going
on with it and what you want them to
know and how they can follow uh this
sport through you sure absolutely if
you're in l.a october 30th at the
burbank marriott lifestyle extreme fight
lxs6 uh get your ticket to lights out
xf.com and then also uh if you're not
there watch us on football sports um
it's going to be live got a three title
shot
uh coming up and uh we're probably gonna
be sold out weeks before so get your
tickets i love it everybody fubu
sportsnetwork.com
saturday october 30th uh lights out
extreme fighting uh with shawn merriman
basically running the show you're the
best sean you take care of yourself
let's do this again soon all right
thanks rich appreciate it that's sean
merriman right here on the rich eisen
show
here on a friday hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here